jennifer de 36 años se contagió de kobe
hace un año en la primera oleada pero
sus síntomas nunca cesaron episodios de
fiebre con sudores nocturnos dificultad
para respirar hay días en los que el
hecho de llevar a mi hijo al colegio es
muy agotador
pero lo que más le preocupa a jennifer
es el dolor en el corazón que apareció
cuando se enfermo
he ido a urgencias tres veces por
petición de mis médicos cada vez que iba
a urgencias no podía caminar porque
tenía mucho dolor me quedaba sin aliento
me mandaron a casa con un analgésico y
me dijeron que es normal que es el
hobbit casi diciendo me deja de quejarte
ya se te pasará
saba pase pero no pasa todo lo contrario
jennifer descubre que el convite le ha
causado una pericarditis una inflamación
de la membrana del corazón
esta misma mañana decidí ir al hospital
americana a visitar a un hospital muy
caro de parís 2 que tengo que pagar yo
mismo que es huapilla para que me
dijeran que tengo secuelas incurables
que se desecha el por culpa de las
personas que me atendieron anteriormente
y no se tomaron en serio mis síntomas
les pagaré por ello el resto de mi vida
hoy jennifer se ha unido a la asociación
aprensiva después del día 20 en español
que nació de los grupos de facebook que
reúnen a las personas que siguen
enfermas después
uno de sus objetivos que se reconozca el
síndrome del coach largo como una
afección de larga duración los pacientes
cuya condición fue reconocida son
atendidos sin tener que pagar los gastos
médicos por adelantado es un presupuesto
enorme cuando uno empieza a haber
especialistas cuando uno toma
tratamientos a largo plazo es costoso
órganos afectados pluralidad y duración
de los síntomas factores de riesgo
investigadores de todo el mundo intentan
definir los contornos de este misterioso
síndrome como aquí en el hospital hotel
de los investigadores del estudio compra
ya han analizado la evolución de 1.700
pacientes de kobe de larga duración
basándonos en las experiencias de los
pacientes identificamos 53
manifestaciones de la enfermedad también
nos interesa el impacto en la enfermedad
en la vida de las personas y nos dimos
cuenta de que es una enfermedad muy
incapacitante para las personas que los
afectan su trabajo en su vida familiar
en la actualidad los siguientes pasos
son ver cómo evolucionan estos síntomas
y responder a una pregunta muy
importante que es cuánto tiempo dura
cuando se tiene un qubit largo
una pregunta que ocupa la mente de
matthew
los persistentes síntomas de este padre
de 38 años le han impedido volver a
trabajar también enfermos desde hace un
año tiene la oportunidad de seguir el
programa de rehabilitación kobe creado
por el profesor marcial
en francia las consultas dedicadas con
el largo siguen siendo muy escasas
el objetivo del juego es quedarse sin
aliento y ver qué pasa cuando sucede
vamos 1 2 3
el objetivo de esta consulta es hacer un
balance de la evolución de la enfermedad
y coordinar el proceso de tratamiento
ya sea el escáner de tórax el análisis
de sangre o la gasometría en el
neumólogo no hay nada fuera de lo común
de acuerdo hablemos de los síntomas que
están mejorando y de los que aún están
presentes y lo molestan que hoy en día
el médico también puede sugerir un
tratamiento farmacológico a algunos
pacientes lo escucho hoy lo que más le
molesta es la falta de concentración el
dolor en las articulaciones la fatiga
así que hoy en día en los casos más
típicos de kobe que tenemos para este
tipo de sintomatología estamos empezando
no hay varios de nosotros haciendo esto
como y prescribiendo antiinflamatorios y
ha tenido algún comentario positivo
sí sí soy mucho más optimista desde
enero muy duro pero para este médico
deportólogo la rehabilitación sigue
siendo un elemento central del
tratamiento
nos preocupaba mucho que se produjeran
daños en los tejidos y en los órganos
en realidad es su sistema de control
interno el que se ha descontrolado a
causa del virus
hay que hacerlo bien hay que
rehabilitarlo
hay que reeducar lo haga
sin embargo aunque empiecen a surgir
opciones de tratamiento el manejo médico
sigue siendo todo un reto
la autoridad pública de la salud acaba
de publicar una vía de atención
específica
el único problema es que hay que tener
personal para apoyar a médicos
enfermeras y fisioterapeutas
y para atender una nueva patología
emergente además de lo que ya hacemos
matthew por su parte está dedicado a
seguir todas las pistas para recuperar
su vida
en cuanto los deje me voy a la misma
farmacia de siempre y me tomo la
medicación y estoy muy motivado confío
mucho en el tratamiento que me han
recetado hoy para recuperarme
rápidamente y que mi vida vuelva a ser
normal